[音楽]
それではせ会見を始めさせていただきます
なぜかんはいなぜここにいるのか分かっているんですかはい
先日私のメインチャンネルで挙げさせていただいた動画の一部の中に
トークというかそのお話する
卵がありましてそのトークの中にその女性の名前が
モザイクかけたんですけれども一瞬ちょっと編集の
こちらの店で
見えてしまっておりまして
その女性の名前が降っていたせいで一部の視聴者そのそして関係者の皆様にご迷惑
をおかけしてしまいそして
お騒がせしてしまったことです
私はないでしょう
本当に
出場者の皆様には
大変なご心配そして
お騒がせさせてしまい本当に申し訳ございませんでした
今回の騒動についてどうお考えですか
はい
実際動画に写り込んでいた女性の名前は
まなみ
という女性のものになるんですけれども
実際にちゃっ通していなくても
1回さあ2アウトトークがこのできちゃって
なので実際にその愛美さんという方とはお話も捨てなくてあの画面上に表示された愛美
さんという方は僕が誤って
まなみさんというユーザーをタッチしてしまって
上に出てきてしまったというトークなんでありまして実際にアプリ内っての会話がなく
ネット上ではですねその
彼女とだという噂がかなり建てられておりますが
そのような事実は一切ございません実際にあの場でチャットをした
お話をしたという事実もございません学びさんとの関係性について教えてもらって良い
ですか
母最も立つかもみたいなその卵がはじまして
そこでたまたまの方がいて6型ボタンを押してしまってをした結果その十
9の画面が出てきちゃって上の方に上がっちゃって最近
七海さんとお話ししたような写り方をしてしまったのではないかなと思っております
一部の人たちの中ではまだ未さんの正体を突き止めようとしていますがそれについては
いかがでしょうか
はい
[音楽]
そう月話をしますと
あの
一瞬女性の名前が
映り込んだだけで
あんな風にその彼女が出来たとかまなみっていうか人は彼女なのみたいな
決めつけですね
事実とは異なる内容
信じ込んでしまいそれを勝手に拡散されたりする事は非常に
迷惑な行為だと
私は感じておりますファンの方々に一言どうぞ
はい
ほんの5分の方なんですけども
実際にその愛美さんという方と付き合ってるみたいな話を信じてしまった方も
大勢いらっしゃいましたが
あの
ネットっていうのは
いろんな情報が飛び交っていて
とても面白い場ではあると思うのですが
事実と異なることが非常に多くもあります
まあその点において
今回園
古文単語記事を一番をせよといっ
今回のような
根も葉もない噂名前が映ってしまっただけで
彼女ないのみたいなそういった憶測で物事を判断してしまうことは非常によろしくない
ことだと私は思っております
ネットの情報を非常に
正しいものが正しくないのかの判断が
難しいものが多いので
そこらへんをしっかり見分ける能力を
まあ大切にしていってもらいたいなと私は思っております
パズ目さんの好きなアイドル manage 麻里さんが卒業することについてどうお
考えですか
女児かよろしく思っておりますまなみさんについてですか
状態がまなみドンネットで上がっているんですがそれについてはどうなんですか
し合ってるなぁ
完璧なぁ
まあ買ってねーっ
でも前日は異なるんです
そういうとこやなんだよではネットの情報はデマということですかねぇ
はい
その件に関しましては
私の子頃からの
脳でございます
ファンの中では
付き合っていてつらいというファンの声もあるんですがそのファンの方々に向けて一言
いただきたいと思います
耳がとって聞こえないんですけど付き合ってる雪が辛いかってるんですけどどう待ち
だって
凝ってるフライヤーこっち楽蔵よ真鍋ちゃんと
しちゃうよ
こっちも見てね root 化されたらキュンと違う
あの本当に
ちゃんと僕がその愛美さんという人と
ツーショットとか
付き合っているようなアレだったら
まあそうもしれませんよ
ただ
ないのでただけでしょ名前が出ただけで可能だったらもうなんにしても彼女じゃない
ですか
だからそっとそういうことでしょうだってあなたたちが痛いことはそうでしょ
何しても彼女なんでしょじゃあ何腕に行っちゃう
南って書いてあったらみなみちゃんってなんか彼女
おかしいねサー z か覗いたっちゃそんな子したらアプリ女の子の名前出たらただ
ドドーが来てるの
ワンちゃんネコ立ってろ落ちてくださいこれ
小川取り乱しました twitter が相互フォローの関係になっているというのが
張ったんでこうなってるんですがそれについてはどう思うんですか
その件に関しましては
以前押す事で一度ご一緒させていただいたことがありましてその件でフォローさせて
いただいていたのですがその仕事の
県以外では
一切連絡を取ったこともなくあったことも一切ございません
ファンのツイートでもし付き合っていたら全力で応援したい
どちらも大好きだからという声があるんですがいかがでしょうか
月明かり売ってたわー応援はありがたいよ俺はありがたいけどそういう思い込みだな
トーゴ follow とラインもつながっているらしいという説があるんですが
line の方はどんなんでスレ立ってない正木さんは相互フォローの関係にあるん
ですか
私はその頃な関係にありませんということはネットに合った学びさんと付き合っている
という間について
それは嘘だという事ですよ
はい
打つとしましては
いしたい
まなみさんという女性とは
関係がございません
すべて
ネットの勝手な憶測噂
そういうもので
作られた
虚言でございます
それではませさん一言お願いします今回の件は本当に
一さんのおっしゃっている通りだと思います
赤城山行きたいところを教えてください
江ノ島ですかね
ちょっとギリギリられるなあー
me